you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
thousands of barrels of possible toxic
waste are discovered off the coast of
california
the solar-powered star trek style ship
with no captain or crew
monitoring the impact of climate change
on our oceans
and the electric racing series raising
awareness of climate change we speak to
nico rosberg about
extreme
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions we aim to take you to the
heart of the climate crisis
explain the data driving the changes
that are already affecting us
but also show you just how far we've
come
and we started again with a possible
toxic
waste site that's been discovered off
the coast of california
now marine scientists mapped tens of
thousands of acres of the sea floor
between
santa catalina island and los angeles
where a massive dumping ground for
industrial waste
has long been suspected now using an
underwater drone they
identified more than 27 000 barrels
of what's thought could be pesticide and
a hundred thousand debris objects on the
sea floor
either bennett reports there are more
than 27 000 of these barrels on the
seabed near california
each one thought to contain the banned
pesticide ddt
they were found 12 miles off los angeles
in an area long suspected of being a
massive toxic waste site
just how big wasn't known until now
shipping logs have previously shown how
industrial companies used it as a
dumping ground until the early 70s
when ddt was banned but high levels of
the pesticide are still being found in
marine mammals here
and the chemicals also been linked to
cancer in sea lions
that prompted a huge survey by
researchers at the university of
california
who used sonar and an underwater drone
to map
36 000 acres of the sea bed and they
were shocked
by what they found it really was a
surprise to everybody
who's worked with the data and who
sailed at sea
humbly really to run the survey and
realize kind of what
what we were beginning to observe on the
seafloor you know it was
staggering really to see kind of the
spatial extent
the scientists found more than a hundred
thousand objects in total
at a depth of 900 meters the barrels
their most concerning discovery
they're estimated to contain up to 700
tons of waste their contents will now be
tested
and if they haven't leaked they'll be
moved to a safer location
but if they have everything here will
need to be sampled
the water sediment and marine life to
see just how much damage
has been done iva bennett sky news
let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate news and scientists
are warning that
air pollution could have a lasting
impact on children's mental health
the 25-year study found young people who
are exposed to high levels of toxic air
are more likely to suffer from a mental
illness in later life
the researchers tested for a range of
psychiatric disorders including anxiety
and adhd
a record number of drinks cans sold in
the uk were recycled last year
new data from the environment agency has
found more than 151
000 tons of aluminium packaging was
collected and recycled
that's a 31 increase on the previous
year
it's being put down to more people using
their local recycling facilities
[Applause]
and pet owners are being encouraged to
put their pooches on a more sustainable
diet
london-based company aardvark has
developed environmentally friendly dog
food that uses
protein from insects rather than animal
meat
they say it produces 80 times less
methane per kilogram
when compared to beef
the world's first autonomous ship is
about to embark on a pioneering journey
to collect critical data about our
oceans
the mayflower 400 will be a floating
laboratory working out
how the world can help protect marine
life and stop the climate crisis
our science correspondent thomas more
reports
[Applause]
this could be the future of ocean
science a floating lab that navigates
itself
around the world powered by the sun with
no
humans on board there's no need for
bunks toilets or a kitchen
leaving more room for robotic
instruments that can give scientists
back on land
live data on the health of our seas the
ocean covers 70
percent of the planet but just 5 has
been explored
it's so vast that much of it is beyond
the reach of scientists
until now inside the mayflower 400
equipment will test the sea water
climate change is making the ocean
warmer and more acidic
putting marine life under pressure
plankton the bottom of the food chain
will be monitored
and it will even listen to whales
to gauge how many there are in the open
ocean the ocean
impacts us all far more than we may even
realize you know it's not just
the food that we eat it's our travel our
trade
and above all it's our climate as well
the ocean regulates our planet to a huge
extent
the mayflower should set off on its
maiden voyage within the next few weeks
a 3000 mile crossing of the atlantic
the engineering team from ibm and
primary are already dreaming of what kit
they could add perhaps even a camera
that's lowered into the depths to look
for new species
the ocean is under threat if scientists
don't know what we stand to lose
we can't save it thomas more sky news in
plymouth
glaciers have been melting more quickly
over the last 20 years than the
greenland or antarctic
ice sheets that's according to a new
study in the journal nature
so here's how much ice has been lost
from the greenland ice sheets every year
181 gigatons
between 2000 and 2018.
now over the same time period 121
gigatons was lost from antarctica
every year and here's the total loss
from glaciers
264 gigatons
now the report calculated that over the
last 20 years the loss of
ice from glaciers has contributed to
around 20 percent
of the global rise in sea levels so
here's what that ice loss actually looks
like now this is the columbia glacier
on the south coast of alaska and this is
what it looked like in the year 2000
now by 2010 the ice at the foot of the
mountains is almost completely melted
and you can see how
thin the surrounding ice is and by 2020
it's retreated more than 20 kilometers
north making it one of the fastest
changing glaciers on the planet
well let's bring in climate scientist dr
ella gilbert from the university of
redding dr ella gilbert what part is
climate change playing in this ice loss
from glaciers
well climate change is causing glaciers
to lose ice by making them melt and
that's especially true of the kind of
warmer parts of the arctic
and places like scandinavia and iceland
but crucially the speed at which they're
shrinking has accelerated in the last 20
years just
because of ongoing climate warming and
how significant
is this what does this mean for sea
levels for example
well ultimately all of that ice has to
go somewhere and it ends up in the ocean
and as you said earlier 21 of the
observed increase in sea level rise
since 2000
has been due to the loss of ice from
glaciers and if my
mass is correct that's around 15
millimeters worth of sea level rise
and what are the risks associated with
sea level rises sea level rise
threatens people all over the world
particularly those in in coastal
communities and
countries that are already close to sea
level small island developing states
like
tuvalu vanuatu and pretty much anyone
who lives
near the coast in any country so what
can we do
to reverse this what can we do to stop
the melt
well the primary thing is to minimize
our emissions so
reducing the amount of climate warming
that goes on
um it's going to be quite difficult to
reverse sea level rise
but we can stop any further sea level
rise occurring
dr ella gilbert thank you the extreme
e racing series is aiming to highlight
the impact of climate change in some of
the world's most endangered environments
the cars taking part use hydrogen fuel
cell technology
with the race fleet charged using zero
emissions energy
it's hoped that the innovations the
teams come up with will help enhance
electric vehicle technology
for the car industry more widely former
f1 champion nico rosberg has his own
team taking part
i spoke to him earlier and started by
asking what the racing series
is all about xtremi is a new motorsports
championship
it's based on fully electric off-road
buggies and we're really here to
raise awareness for climate change um
but also have local
impact with projects that we're
supporting so it's really the first
sport
sport that's built on a social purpose
and talk us through the locations that
you've chosen for the various races
and why they've been picked out
so we've carefully picked these
spectacular locations around the world
like for example racing near the glacier
in greenland
but unfortunately at the same time these
locations are the ones that have
been damaged most by climate change and
we're racing there because
first of all we want to support the
local initiatives and the locals
in their fight against climate change
but also secondly
we want to raise awareness for climate
change and really show
people around the world what's happening
around around the planet
and has your experience with extreme e
may you reflect at all
on your time in formula one any
environmental regrets
formula one let's not forget has already
done a lot also for mobility i mean
we've been pioneering lightweight
materials we've pioneered the
turbocharged engines
pioneered hybrid engines which is a
great contemporary uh powertrain
solution
at the moment very efficient um but at
the same time i'm also proud because
f1 is doing more and more um to also
become more sustainable uh pledging to
be carbon neutral by 2030
and this is where extreme e is really
trailblazing we're already a carbon
neutral event now
uh powered by hydrogen energy um and
we're doing a lot you know really
launching these initiatives around the
world to have real impact
tangible impact locally and that's what
i love about xtreme
okay nico stay with me because in a
moment we're also going to be speaking
to adam
bond from afc energy who supply the
power for
the extreme e-cars but first we can show
you now what the racing looks like
these pictures here are from the first
race which took place in
saudi arabia johan christopher's in
doing the switch and
on that switch they picked up a one
minute penalty and it really ends in
what could have been
a really nice lead for them they would
have been top qualifier they were about
four
so adam bond welcome to you you're
involved in the technology behind the
fueling of these cars hydrogen fuel
cells so explain to us how they work and
just how green are they sure look
hydrogen fuel cells
is a zero emission power generator
really our systems that we've uh
designed for the xtreme
uh championship from from from racing in
a lula all the way through to greenland
amazon
at every one of the locations that
niko's reference you know the idea is to
generate zero emission power to charge
the cars
to promote and be fully consistent with
the sustainable message of the
of the extreme e uh championship so uh
we are generating zero emission power
it's displacing diesel generation and uh
it's really big
it's the first uh first of its kind for
for international motor racing and and
we believe international sporting
well nico rosberg and adam bond we
appreciate your time thanks so much for
joining us today
and you can see that full interview with
nico rosberg at youtube.com sky news
and that's everything from us for today
on the daily climate show tomorrow
we hear about an ambitious plan to stop
flooding along britain's longest river
that's at the same time tomorrow here on
sky news see you then
[Music]
you